hey guys Ryan right over here hey guys
salamandra sizee an apple and as we're
gonna do this we're gonna check out
minions the official trailer number
three to Despicable Me prequel yeah I
want I mean I want a minion I did you
actually I just want a yellow [ __ ]
yeah you do huh minions have you ever
wondered where they came from
they've been on this planet far longer
than we have
they're all different but they all share
the same game to find a villain ah
Oh finding a master is easy keeping a
master where things got tricky
nope it wasn't easy for these guys but
nonetheless they kept on looking
hello but i getta today I am working for
the greatest supervillain
Oh
these are the new recruits no no don't
see anything I won't understand do you
know who this is is that yeah this
Elizabeth school and I really really
really want her crown you came for the
Queen's crown teach it whoa yeah
ah
gentlemen oops
crowns don't you starlet me I don't want
to take this the wrong way but I hate
you guys cut up this is really
unprofessional
I'm a little surprised by that trailer
really yeah I mean it looks looks funny
it looks adorable but seems I'm it seems
kind of dark doesn't it swords and all
the deaths in the first part of the
trailer I'm at like the other toying
with it history like making historical
fiction of the minions but shot heard
around the world is actually I mean but
you know it does make sense for to be a
little dark I mean these minions are
gravitated towards villains right and
they want to serve the villains I like
seeing that I like how the trailers are
not give in a way that GRU might make an
appearance or just add the complete
backstory like I hate trailers that tell
the whole entire story in the room this
one like just gives you clips to really
want to actually watch it and it's gonna
be fun to see because they serve GRU
which is a man now they'll be serving
Sandra Bullock's character whose name I
already forgot um
scarlet but yeah like well all the
deaths the Rope that seems to be a lot
of darkness and in this trailer that is
and there's even like some raunchy humor
too like when he lifts up the shitty the
boobs yeah like this doesn't seem like
the most child appropriate it's cuz like
mainly adults just love minions like
whenever I see people with minions stuff
it's usually adults that's surely
DreamWorks Animation it tends to be more
adults actually I'm allergic to like
that I had a lot of adult yeah yeah yeah
which I like it's kind of you know cuz
they do disney-esque stuff but they kind
of you know bring it up a notch yeah
that he doesn't do that at all ouch they
kind of do this is awesome does he is
awesome they brought us Tarzan we are
coming out with a Latina princess though
so yeah well that performs anyway guys
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out salamander Sally's channel a
variety of stuff on there check it out
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter or product
placement sex show goes here and then
and bam we do a shout out david merengue
hey Ryann and pals I can't believe I
used the word pals well believe it David
you did I love your channel and the
gorgeous ladies on it except Veronica
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
no I feel like he said that because he
doesn't want to like disrespect you cuz
you're dating her because he put a
smiley face why would your confusing you
he has a game channel sure sure it's
good I think I made good content but no
one knows about it I wonder why I
greatly appreciate you giving me head a
shout out of Awesomeness I made a
Facebook account just for this message
that's cute
I can't tell because it's texted whether
or not he was insulting my girlfriend so
do I tell people about arranged Rover ma
RA n GE Rover do I mention that do I
promote it in some fashion for him no I
shouldn't promote my Range Rover because
he insulted my girlfriend I mean for all
I know my Range Rover is probably a very
unique gaming channel that features a
lot of new content that you don't really
get from other gaming channels but it's
not right to promote him No mm-hmm oh we
reso mentioned it oh my god work we're
[ __ ] stupid Camry silly